♪ (MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
SAM LEVINSON:
I always write to music
and as I was writing Euphoria,
I kept hearing Danny Elfman...
♪ (CURIOUS MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
-...meets Yeezus...
-♪ (ELECTRONIC BEATS) ♪
...meets gospel...
♪ (GOSPEL TONES) ♪
...which sounds really weird.
♪ (COMBINATION
OF MUSIC STYLES) ♪
Labrinth is the first person
who's like, "Yeah."
♪ ("EUPHORIA" THEME PLAYS) ♪
I felt like I knew exactly
what he wanted to go for.
The wonderful thing about Lab
is he works from
just pure inspiration.
Most score writers, they have
a very traditional way
of writing.
They've gone to school,
so they're used to
a certain sound, and for me,
I feel like Euphoria
told me what to do.
Whatever makes me
feel excited,
I'm gonna find a way
of injecting it into the music.
♪ (THEME CONTINUES) ♪
♪ Feel the morning ♪
♪ On my face ♪
For me, with every scene,
it was just like,
"How can I elevate it
but do it in a modern,
but fresh way?"
Labrinth would bring out
certain hues in the show.
LABRINTH: I wanted to merge
different genres,
and a lot of my music
has influences
of classic '70s rock,
but also has orchestral
arrangements,
along with hip-hop.
I kinda have two styles,
maybe my angel
and my devil side.
♪ (ETHEREAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
LABRINTH:
I'm a very spontaneous creative.
One day, I wanna make
a house record...
♪ (DANCE MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
...the next day, I wanna make
a classical record...
♪ (ORCHESTRAL MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
...the next day, I wanna make
an electronic record.
♪ (ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
I'm not a precious person.
When I write music,
I'm like, "Let's all get
involved together."
Every collaboration helps
develop my music.
♪ ("EUPHORIA" THEME PLAYS) ♪
LEVINSON:
There's nothing we love more
than to just sit there
and cut Lab's music.
And just play around with it.
We'll play it backwards,
we'll strip it up,
and just try different things.
So, it becomes this, uh,
this good, sort of,
you know, back and forth.
JULIO: It's a very, very unique
relationship with a composer
that's, uh, I don't know,
led to, I think,
a very one-of-a-kind texture.
♪ (THEME CONTINUES) ♪
♪ I'm livin' for the thrill ♪
LABRINTH: Whatever the score
needed, I would adjust my style.
Euphoria gave me the freedom
to be whatever artist
I wanna be.
There's this, kind of,
hopefulness to his music
that feels triumphant
and serves as, kind of,
a north star for the series
itself.
Labrinth's score was just...
better than I could
ever dream of.
♪ ( THEME CONTINUES) ♪